would you ban tick tock I would I think
so would you I think so I mean I think
from everybody in America I think I
think it's a security risk I think they
are harvesting so much data on our
citizens there's a whole bunch of other
apps and stuff that are out there and
honestly Pierce I got young kids I don't
want our kids on some of this stuff
would you okay so he would indeed ban
Tick Tock listen the danger with
DeSantis is he although he's incredibly
low energy and low charisma
he very casually will present ideas as
though yeah you know yeah yeah okay yeah
and so you always sort of come away like
well he doesn't seem very ideological
because like it sounds like he's sort of
like softly in this camp but he could
easily be pulled over here this is
really the trick of DeSantis where then
when you look at his actual record it's
this wacky anti-woke delusion fighting
the culture wars and extraordinarily
authoritarian as we've covered before so
a very interesting interview